remember not to go out like crazy from the
start for the
first 30 seconds so that you can be well
armed and wait until
the Argentine Republic is called
qualified.
the prettiest boxer in
Argentina what the hell is this take away they
pay me well they pay a lot of twine
you're here because you're an [ __ ] that
the woman threw the [ __ ] out of Argentina she was right
you don't think so
[Applause]
that's not a volcano it's  a showman
is Arming the television Oscar eh
tell me Ringo
my love
Look at me Look at me well because you will never
see me like this
dad will never be old
break his face
[Applause]
Hi baby
Crazy
a title fight or a
big bag in the middle no  there is nothing
Let me be world champion I
will not be able to die in peace I
am Ringo buenavena don't forget
[Music]